oh yes let's see here inventory weapons
this I'll have to cure this bad boy this
right here and this I'll have to pull
right here Jesus okay let's get EC's
controls
so how do i cancel
[ __ ] out through the [ __ ] heads off
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] is all that shooting is that oh
Jesus that's so good oh my god okay okay
blow this guy's hands off
yeah good except right careful hey
[ __ ] psycho yeah let me see what I
got a [ __ ] do
promise yes uh I got this way come this
way
Oh is a good [ __ ] here okay oh [ __ ] a to
turn oh good I got it I got it oh [ __ ]
should I proceed Jack one
hmm ok ok [ __ ] I gotta go up I guess
yeah I gotta go up wait hella [ __ ] over
there my bad my bad wait it was in our
roof it was like a heli bird on the roof
or something
okay have to get over that okay I got it
I got it duder presents girls [ __ ]
bed us
it's gonna be a little sick nasty you
know oh [ __ ]
the [ __ ] now that was a [ __ ] monster
answer again isn't [ __ ] things like
time now oh [ __ ]
up here but somebody up here Oh chef
now shut [ __ ] is getting [ __ ] real
okay where's that last firing from [ __ ]
[ __ ] is that great
yeah that thing has a lot of [ __ ]
house
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] a the thing is a beast
Oh
oh [ __ ] okay I gotta die right here oh
my god how do you [ __ ] heal am I
still in here Oh Solomon that was a
pretty amazing display yeah I'm just
glad you are on our side okay got again
the feeling's mutual president you can
never have too many friends not in the
Commonwealth listen when we first met
you said you were glad to help well you
did and we owe you our lives hmm thanks
so here in your life what is the best
way i can say thank you and I said oh my
name
I didn't do it for money hey sorry I'm
used to everyone being in it only for
themselves no try me my friends the
other Minutemen the ones who gave their
lives for something bigger than
themselves you should come with us to
sanctuary we could use the help Jake
you're worried all right Garvey oh
that's wonderful but this water your
destiny isn't there uh toggle faster
please tell me I would hope all's not
lost I can feel the sun's energy he's
alive I knew it please tell me where he
is I need to find my son I can't see him
not clearly but I feel his life force
he's out there and even i don't need the
site to tell you where you should start
looking oh great green jewel of the
Commonwealth diamond city the biggest
settlement around aah cut cut cut please
nothing I need more look kid I'm tired
now maybe you know mama Murphy we talked
about this that junk don't worry we're
all gonna die thank you sure to
sanctuary we're gonna need the site
music you friend here
he's gonna like you better go into
diamond city let's get going sanctuary
awaits all right folks thanks to our
friend here it's safe to move out we're
heading for that place mama Murphy knows
about sanctuary it's not far she knows
about it you mean she had one of her
visions while she was stoned out of her
gourd and now you want us to just head
out on another wild-goose chase based on
no better plan than mama I could have
the same ol hours then everybody just
take it easy we're all in this together
right so Marci got a better idea of what
we should do next anybody well then
sanctuary it is let's just hope it lives
up to its name come on jun it's time to
go oh ok now you see there it is oops
wait what the [ __ ] that I just do a wash
drop [ __ ] ok ah not good not good take
take ok a tie again get get get we owe
you no doubt about that following
diamond cities
hmm okay interesting loading screens
haven't seen like that a lot of time
someone's archaic don't forget the price
we paid to get this bar let's move out
I'll take point stay close everyone
we're right behind you boss I love San
close Thank You keg a little faster
chase s weird that [ __ ] deathclaw
burst of crying here right how you guys
r it out of here Jesus
okay okay what's this think and I just
like meat on there okay I'm just [ __ ]
flying there
um it's just dude here has a radio still
work okay now is that what is that oh
what heck freedom calls join him at
sanctuary here yet oh he's halfway there
do I have to make a bed and stuff ram
okay food is panel towards fences
miscellaneous cage like Paul oh the heck
I need utilities resources there we go
water yeah can only be placed and Derek
good good no concrete [ __ ] I love any of
this [ __ ] okay
I'm serious dude is he's almost there
come on this way and I'll exactly see
them oh there ya [ __ ] slow 10 whose
bodies like a [ __ ] killed off
I'm glad you decided to come with us I
should have listened to mama Murphy all
along pretty nice place she's found four
uh-huh I think we could settle down here
make it a place to call home what do you
think oh yes yes yeah I used to like
living here before the war what do you
mean before what water are you saying I
lived here over 200 years ago I was
frozen or something for most of it just
woke up a little while ago damn like one
of those old pre-war ghoul uh yeah
something like that anybody else make it
out with you my son somebody took him
away while i was still traffic damn I'm
sorry right press some just shine be
real with you know let me know if
there's any way I can help out thank you
thank you I am glad you're here gut gut
and I hope you don't mind but I've got
another what I've had word from a
settlement asking for help there's still
hoping their mini man out there
somewhere the only chance to start
rebuilding the minuteman is to show
people that they can count on us when
they need